e il 3 marzo del 2006 sono le 5 del
mattino squilla il mio telefono
cellulare all'epoca non era una cosa
insolita per l'incarico che ricopriva la
cosa insolita e ragga a chiamarmi fosse
direttamente il capo del servizio
centrale operativo che per noi
poliziotti è la massima autorità nel
campo delle indagini mi dice che fai
dormi hai sentito cosa è successo a
parma ancora stordito gli rispondo la
nasa non sveglio so tutto oralmente non
era vero lui l'ha capito
lo dice bene prepara la strumentazione
viene in ufficio con la valigia porta
chi vuoi dei tuoi tanto tra poco ci
vediamo in ufficio all'epoca era un
giovane funzionario mi occupavo di
intercettazioni e di indagini
elettroniche ed era la prima volta che
un investigatore di quel calibro mi
chiamava direttamente sul mio telefono
cellulare e per questo motivo ero
veramente gasata dopo due ore
sull'autostrada per parma dov'era stato
rapito un bambino un bambino di 18 mesi
tommaso onofri quel bimbo che di lì a
poco per tutta l'italia sarebbe
diventato il piccolo tommy
da quel giorno a parma è partita
un'indagine pazzesca avevamo ritmi di
lavoro allucinanti praticamente non
dormivamo mai le tracce che avevamo a
disposizione non aveva mai sufficienti
per dirci se la vista che seguiva mar
aveva la giusta se realmente saremmo
arrivati ai rapitori
considerate che seguivamo almeno dieci
vista in contemporanea per una che
riuscivamo ad escluderne ne subentra un
altre due non potevamo trascurare nulla
avevamo nelle mani la vita di un bimbo
anche le piste assurde come le visioni
dei maghi anche quelle devono essere
vagliate
io avevo parecchi problemi
doveva analizzare i tabulati e in base
alle celle capire se determinati
soggetti erano non erano sulla scena
ma non ci riuscivo il ritmo delle
indagini era incalzante facevo delle
localizzazioni ci mettevo una settimana
a volte facevano errore di un chilometro
e questo non andava assolutamente bene e
quando mi giravo vedevo gli altri miei
colleghi che lavorano su altri settori
avevano gli stessi problemi
ci sono voluti trenta lunghissimi giorni
per trovare ed arrestare i rapitori del
piccolo tommy che purtroppo era stato
ucciso venti minuti dopo il sequestro
perché piangeva qualsiasi sforzo sarebbe
comunque stato inutile
quel giorno si è concluso il mio
battesimo del fuoco quelle attività che
mi aveva posto faccia a faccia con tutti
i miei limiti
e i limiti del mio ufficio ed è proprio
quel giorno davanti a quel corpicino che
ci siamo detti che così non poteva
andare
non poteva andare che cosa era la
polizia scientifica
la polizia scientifica era un gruppo di
tecnici che applicava delle tecniche
delle metodologie nella maggior parte di
casi alla perfezione senza errori ma di
tecniche erano sempre le stesse
a volte anche vecchie di dieci anni
quando un investigatore c formulava una
domanda che esulava dall'ordinario la
risposta
quello che noi rispondevamo più in
generale era questo non si può fare
c'era addirittura gli rispondevano
facciamo così perché abbiamo sempre
fatto così
oggi io sono qui per raccontarvi come è
cambiata la polizia scientifica e come
abbiamo fatto per cambiarla
appena sono tornato da parla ma mi sono
messo subito a lavorare su quelli che
erano i miei problemi
ho preso un software che ho utilizzato
per la mia tesi di laurea
questo mi permetteva di georeferenziare
alcuni dati e di effettuare delle
analisi statistiche lo abbiamo unito da
uno strumento di misura e abbiamo
realizzato un metodo infallibile per
l'analisi delle celle
altro che parma qui in poche ore
otteniamo un dato con la precisione del
m lo abbiamo applicato in tutte le
indagini successive con un successo
notevole ma non ci siamo formati li
abbiamo continuato a studiare a
lavorarci sopra
e alla fine siamo riusciti ad arrivare
ad una rappresentazione tridimensionale
dei tabulati una cosa che neanche ci
speravamo ma oggi alla polizia
scientifica non è cambiata solo questo
oggi la polizia scientifica è cambiato
tutto vi ricordate il 7 dicembre del
2011 quando la squadra mobile di napoli
dopo 15 anni di latitanza arrestato
michele zagaria il capo dei casalesi è
stato trovato in un bunker sotterraneo e
volete sapere come abbiamo fatto a
trovarlo anche grazie alle
intercettazioni e senza neanche usa una
microspia
noi abbiamo seguito l'evoluzione di
queste [ __ ] spire dagli anni 90 dove
c'erano quella analogica fino al 2000
con l'avvento del digitale fino ai
giorni d'oggi
oggi non abbiamo bisogno neanche della
microspia di chi va a collocarla ci
basta inserire un software in un piccino
in un telefono attivare un microfono e
la stessa cosa la potremmo dire per la
cattura di bernardo provenzano il capo
dei capi di cosa nostra e stato
catturato grazie a sofisticatissime
delle camere che da chilometri di
distanza ci permettevano di monitorare
tutti gli spostamenti dei suoi uomini e
anche qui di questi sistemi abbiamo
seguito l'evoluzione dagli anni 90 al
2000 fino ad oggi vi ricordate il 28
settembre del 1988 venne ucciso in un
agguato il giornalista mauro rostagno
dopo 23 anni di indagine gli errori
giudiziari e di depistaggi soltanto nel
2011 e stato riaperto il processo e
questa volta con l'ipotesi dell'omicidio
di mafia di un omicidio commesso per
punire un uomo libero che scriveva ciò
che pensava con la riapertura del
processo siamo in grado di utilizzare le
nuove tecniche che abbiamo messo a punto
nel campo delle indagini e merceologiche
pensare da alcuni frammenti di un fanale
riportati sulla scena del crimine
siamo riusciti ad attribuirli alla fiat
tipo dei killer a questi anni fa era
impensabile
perché perché un vedere un bevera una
plastica era una plastica
oggi siamo in grado di identificare quel
vetro e di capirne la provenienza
quel vetro quella plastica quel tessuto
quella fibra con la vernice quel metallo
pensate a quel dna la prova regina che
non solo ci permette di risolvere i
delitti che avvengono oggi ma anche
quelli che sono avvenuti tanti anni fa
sono rimasti insoluti
perché oggi siamo in grado di leggere
quelle tracce che anni fa non potevano
essere lette grazie all'amplificazione
una tecnica che da una singola molecola
ci permette di ottenere migliaia di
sequenze di dna
in poche parole se prima per estrarre il
dna avevo bisogno di una certa quantità
di sostanza come ad esempio una chiazza
di sangue
oggi è sufficiente una cellula una
cellula di sfaldamento e vite riale che
la mia per le rilascia quando tocco un
oggetto la stessa cosa la potremmo dire
per le impronte digitali sono
l'accertamento storico di polizia
scientifica il più antico ne usiamo da
oltre un secolo ma soltanto oggi ne
sfruttiamo appieno le potenzialità
pensate che non è neanche necessario
dietro un impronta sulla scena del
crimine in basta un frammento lo possa
inserire nella mia banca dati e capire
che appartiene vedere questi studenti in
piazza stanno manifestando siamo a
reggio calabria l'anno al 2005 siamo
indignati sono indignati e protestano
perché è stato ucciso il via locri il
vicepresidente del consiglio regionale
della calabria francesco fortugno è
stato ucciso da un killer a volto
coperto con 5 colpi d'arma da fuoco
dentro il seggio dove si svolgevano le
elezioni primarie del suo partito
volete sapere come abbiamo fatta
risalire agli esecutori materiali e ai
mandanti di quell'omicidio
tutti i condannati in cassazione ci
siamo riusciti grazie al primo match
automatico della banca dati delle
indagini balistiche una banca dati che
contiene al suo interno tutte le
immagini di bossoli e proiettili
riportati in varie scene
e le correla tra loro in sostanza quella
banca dati ci ha detto che la pistola
che aveva ucciso fortugno era la stessa
che aveva sparato un anno prima a locri
durante una festa di paese dove un tizio
per goliardia aver esploso dei colpi in
aria stata chiamata la volante avrebbe
curati bosso avevamo messo in banca dati
a quel punto è stato più semplice capire
chi aveva sparato alla festa e
attraverso l'arma per risalire agli
assassini
noi su questa banca dati abbiamo
investito tantissimo
pensate che oggi sulla scena del crimine
se non trovo un proiettile non fa niente
mi basta una scheggia anche quella può
essere inserita banca dati ed è utile
per un confronto perché ci lavorano su
dati tridimensionali abbiamo più
informazioni
ricordate la vicenda del papello il
famoso documento al centro della
trattativa tra lo stato e la mafia
per noi era fondamentale capire se quel
documento fosse autentico e per capirlo
dovevamo datare avevamo applicato ben 6
tecniche d'indagine merceologica ma
ancora non c'eravamo riusciti alla fine
per la prima volta in un'indagine di
quel tipo
abbiamo dovuto applicare la tecnica del
carbonio 14
e per farlo ci siamo dovuti far aiutare
da un istituto di ricerca un ente
specializzato perché la strumentazione è
complicatissima grande con una stanza la
potete vedere qui nelle immagini oggi
alla polizia scientifica
abbiamo imparato ad innovare non diciamo
più si è sempre fatto così
oggi diciamo cercare di capire come lo
possiamo fare meglio
questo è il nostro obiettivo
abbiamo imparato a fare ricerca o a
farla fare a chi è più bravo di noi
abbiamo imparato a cercare le migliori
tecnologie sul mercato e calarle nel
nostro ambito oggi una meta del nostro
personale lavora sui casi ordinari e
l'altra metà a fare ricerca e interviene
soltanto nei casi più complessi
tecnicamente più importanti a livello
nazionale vi potrei dire che le potremmo
considerare un po le teste di cuoio
della scienza
non siamo più una struttura ferma
noi siamo una struttura in movimento una
struttura che cammina che fa passi
avanti
ogni volta che facciamo un passo avanti
aumenta il nostro know how ed entra a
far parte della nostra cultura
investigativa e questo fa pendere l'ago
della bilancia sempre più dalla parte
della giustizia ma non solo
ogni volta che facciamo un passo in
avanti c'è un altro vantaggio che è
l'effetto sorpresa
ricordate quando sono usciti i primi
telefoni cellulari
nessuno pensava alle intercettazioni
tanto che era molto facile incastrare i
delinquenti
vabbè oggi non è più così è tutto più
conosciuto e poi ci sono i criminali
incalliti quelli che appartengono a
lucrezio alle organizzazioni mafiose al
terrorismo anche loro innovano e
comunque se non innovano
seguono da vicino i nostri progressi
impararlo lasciare le tracce
e poi c'è la spettacolarizzazione dei
processi al giorno d'oggi ci sono
giornali e televisioni che si alimentano
esclusivamente di cronaca nera e gli
piace mostrare tutte le tecniche
investigative nel 2005 a londra ci fu un
attentato alla metropolitana dove
morirono 56 persone
dopo pochi giorni ce ne fu un altro che
fortunatamente falli uno dei
responsabili venne arrestato proprio a
roma il 4 settembre dalla polizia il
giorno successivo su tutti i giornali
c'era scritto in dettaglio come aveva
fatto alla polizia scientifica a
localizzare la vita per questo motivo
noi dobbiamo sempre dobbiamo essere
sempre un passo avanti non ci possiamo
fermare dobbiamo camminare ma dobbiamo
anche camminare velocemente
infatti abbiamo messo a punto delle
nuove tecniche chiaramente oggi qui me
le posso raccontare lo capirete
però una cosa la posso dire
tutti hanno bisogno di innovare non
siano le aziende hi tech che lo fanno
per mestiere ma anche piccole grandi e
medie imprese le pubbliche
amministrazioni la scuola i privati e il
numero è difficile però il messaggio che
vi voglio dare oggi e crea polizia
scientifica ce l'ha fatta ce l'ha fatta
anche se appartiene alla pubblica
amministrazione una tra le più grandi
una delle più complesse
la nostra pubblica amministrazione
gerarchica e gestita con regole ferree
la potremmo definire militarizzata dove
tutto è scritto nella carta dove tutto è
tramandato
eppure ci siamo riusciti anche se è
difficile e comunque la cosa più
difficile di tutti è stata cambiare le
persone superare la mentalità le
abitudini e la cultura delle persone
questo è stato lo scoglio più grande da
superare
volete sapere come abbiamo fatto ci
siamo riusciti perché alcuni dei nostri
migliori investigatori e tecnici forense
hanno fatto carriera hanno vissuto delle
esperienze come la mia sono arrivati a
contatto con i vertici della nostra
amministrazione
alcuni di loro sono diventati essi
stessi vertici e hanno trasmesso la
cultura del cambiamento e l'esigenza
dell'innovazione e da quel momento ci
hanno rimosso gli ostacoli è stata dura
perché abbiamo doveri programmare gli
uffici ristrutturarci cambiare la nostra
organizzazione gerarchica a cambiare
tutta la struttura ma la cosa veramente
importante è con chi lo abbiamo fatto
questo cambiamento
l'abbiamo fatto arruolando tutta una
serie di giovani motivati e preparati
gli abbiamo dato fiducia e
responsabilità allora ci hanno ripagato
e da quel momento abbiamo ricominciato a
correre
voglio dire che se anche tutte le
amministrazioni pubbliche e private
facessero la stessa cosa secondo me
tutto il paese potrebbe rimettersi a
correre
voglio concludere dicendo vi perché lo
abbiamo fatto proprio noi perché
comunque noi siamo la polizia e quando
lavoriamo ad un caso abbiamo sempre
nelle mani la sicurezza anzi diciamo la
vita delle persone
dedico questo dolce al piccolo tommy